تحت شعار قبل فوات الاوان اطلقت الامم
المتحده نداءا لجمع الاموال لمساعدته 30
مليون طفل يعانون من سوء التغذيه حاده في
بلدان متضرره من ازمه الغذاء واكدت 35
تابعه للامم المتحده في بيان المشترك ان
اكثر من 30 مليون طفل ينتمون ل 15 بلد هم
الاكثر تضررا ويعانون من الهزال والهزال
الشديده ومن هذه الدول المتضرره افغانستان
وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد واثيوبيا وهايتي
ومالي والنيجر والصومال والسودان واليمن
ويؤدي الارتفاع الهائل في الاسعار الى
تفاقم نقص الغذاء كما يعوق الوصول الى
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه باسعار معقوله
واوضح البيان ان النزاعات وتغير المناخ
وجائحه
زادت الوضع سوءا مع تحذيره من تفاقم الوضع
في العام الحالي كما شدت الامم المتحده
على ضروره تقدي دعم عاجل الى البلدان
الاكثر تضررا لحمايه حياه الاطفال وصحهتهم
[موسيقى]